[Musica]
voglio essere molto sincera con voi sono
una persona che lavora tantissimo che
vive tutto molto intensamente E che ha
una vita piuttosto frenetica e come
tante altre persone mi faccio prendere
dall'entusiasmo dai miei interessi e
anche dal senso del dovere e questo mi
rende molto difficile misurare le mie
energie ma quello che sto cercando di
fare è imparare l'arte della Temperanza
e allora volevo proporlo anche a voi non
si tratta quindi di un segreto che ho da
svelarvi per rendere la vostra vita
perfetta Anche perché non credo che si
possa avere una vita perfetta né
tantomeno se una vita perfetta sia in
realtà desiderabile perché perfetto
etimologicamente significa compiuto
finito e invece penso che una vita
autentica sia una vita imperfetta in
movimento e che lo scopo almeno Per
quanto mi riguarda sia acquisire
consapevolezza e quello che quindi
voglio proporvi è uno strumento della
filosofia Antica che potrebbe aiutarvi a
misurare le vostre energie a compiere
delle scelte nella direzione
dell'equilibrio e soprattutto del
rispetto verso voi stessi perché oggi
Infatti siamo portati a considerarci
come delle macchine che devono essere
sempre attive sempre performative
funzionare perfettamente non fermarsi
mai e questo troppo spesso ci porta che
cosa stanchezza cronica calo di
entusiasmo e a una domanda tristissima e
purtroppo molto frequente Ma chi me lo
fa fare Ecco in effetti se mostrassimo a
un filosofo antico la nostra vita sempre
di corsa voi cosa credete che direbbe
Probabilmente sì ritroverebbero una
narrazione infernale Si domanderebbe ma
cosa è diventato l'essere umano davvero
lavorate così tanto davvero non vi
fermate mai e soprattutto davvero vi
sentite in colpa quando vi riposate
antico potremmo dare un sacco di
spiegazioni potremmo dire che facciamo
quello che facciamo perché ci piace
perché lo amiamo perché abbiamo tante
responsabilità o perché abbiamo un
obiettivo futuro da raggiungere Ebbene
vi assicuro che non crederebbe a nessuna
di queste giustificazioni Però c'è da
dire qualcosa in verità perché già
nell'antica Roma non è che se la
passasse in una maniera tanto ideale
Come a volte pensiamo certo non
mettevano cinque sveglie la mattina per
svegliarsi e sono abbastanza sicura che
molti di voi lo facciano io ne metto tre
e non avevano probabilmente i calendari
digitali e forse erano neanche il senso
di inadeguatezza la sindrome
dell'impostore l'ansia che abbiamo Oggi
però un po' di fretta ce lo avevano
perché se non fosse stato così nel 49
dopo Cristo Lucio al neo Seneca uno dei
grandi filosofi stoici dell'epoca di
ritorno Sì in Corsica non avrebbe
scritto il discorso sulla brevità della
vita che è in sostanza una lettera
rivolta Pompeo Paolino in cui riversa
tutto il suo disgusto verso i
contemporanei e il modo di vivere
Insomma dei suoi contemporanei il punto
di partenza di questa lettera in
sostanza una lamentela durissima che gli
esseri umani rivolgono riguardo alla
brevità della vita la vita è troppo
breve non c'è abbastanza
tempo per fare le cose che vogliamo fare
e neanche per riposarsi e neanche per
fare tutto quello che si desidera e
scene che invece in questa lettera muove
un'obiezione in una maniera estremamente
dura e puntuale cioè dice che non è vero
che abbiamo poco tempo il vero problema
è che di tempo ne sprechiamo tantissimo
dovremmo considerare la vita non in
termini di lunghezza ma in termini di
profondità però cos'è che accade che ci
facciamo distrarre sprechiamo tempo in
energie in cose insignificanti e diamo
troppa importanza a delle cose che in
realtà non ne hanno Ecco Oggi ci
facciamo un'immagine un po' romanzata
della vita degli antichi romani quindi
forse avete pensato finora ve la siete
immaginata come la vita di chi poteva
passeggiare sui sanpietrini con i
sandali di cuoio tutto il giorno e
vivere un'atmosfera poetica rilassata
conversando di politica in realtà quello
che ci racconta Seneca è una una vita
completamente diversa e cioè persone
sempre di corsa con tante cose da fare
obblighi impegni che continuavano a
rimandare il momento di riposarsi e il
momento in cui dedicarsi alle cose che
per loro contavano davvero i loro
interessi più speciali più più
coinvolgenti dicendo ho troppo da fare
Non posso fermarmi forse
quando mi ritirerò a vita privata ma
adesso Ecco sono abbastanza sicura che
vi ricordi qualcuno e probabilmente quel
qualcuno siete voi Ecco Diciamoci la
verità quello che ancora oggi tendiamo a
fare e rimandare il momento del piacere
il momento di riposo e anche il momento
di cura nei confronti di noi stessi e
allora capita che quello che si dica sia
quando sarà in pensione finalmente potrò
riposarmi quando i nostri figli saranno
grandi finalmente
che potremmo viaggiare Quando smetterò
di lavorare mi dedicherò a fare le cose
che mi piacciono davvero le mie grandi
passioni Ecco quello che crediamo quando
diciamo così e che la vita sia una linea
retta in cui noi abbiamo il controllo
quindi questa cosa non posso farla
adesso e la rimando però non funziona
così perché noi non abbiamo controllo
sul futuro Questo è un'illusione non
sappiamo cosa ci riserva ci sono troppi
fattori troppi variabili su cui non
abbiamo controllo e quindi rimandare il
piacere il riposo e la fioritura
personale è un'illusione che impoverisce
le nostre vite e il presente e ci fa
diventare questo ci rende questo solo un
tempo di fatica e di sudore quello che
ci illudiamo di fare è di poter
accumulare un credito con la vita che a
un certo punto potremmo riscattare lo
riscatteremo Quando saremo vecchi ma
questo non significa vivere perché il
tempo deve essere utilizzato bene in
questo momento
ma non può essere neanche ottimizzato e
capitalizzato come a volte pensiamo di
fare perché utilizzarlo bene non
significa necessariamente
usarlo in ogni secondo e cercare di
tenerlo e di ottimizzarlo secondo Seneca
c'è stata concessa una vita abbastanza
lunga e anche abbastanza generosa per
realizzare grandi cose solo che non la
occupiamo in maniera appropriata quindi
per coloro che la sanno gestire bene
l'esistenza può essere ampia profonda e
abbondante però voi A questo punto mi
chiederete Ma come si fa cioè come
possiamo essere buoni custodi di questo
tempo a disposizione
gli antichi ci avrebbero detto trovando
la giusta misura ancora una volta Facile
a dirsi è come si trova questa giusta
misura le giusta misura e l'arte della
Temperanza o soppressione Come si dice
in greco un concetto che ha radici
proprio nella filosofia e nell'etica ed
è una virtù che indica l'equilibrio
delle passioni dei desideri e dei
comportamenti e implica moderazione
autocontrollo e saggezza della Condotta
e nel consumo Qual è invece l'idea che
oggi è tanto diffusa Secondo me è
qualcosa di molto simile a un altro
concetto dell'antica Grecia che è la
iubris cioè una la tracotanza Cioè quel
concetto che
implica l'idea di non riconoscere la
giusta misura pensare di non avere
limiti e di poter fare qualunque cosa
nella mitologia greca Se vi ricordate
pensate a Tantalo Per esempio questo
porta la vendetta la punizione Divina la
tisis e anche la filosofia metteva in
guardia del pericolo di un comportamento
esagerato e da questa visione distorta
della propria grandezza e metteva in
pericolo rispetto al considerare un
eccesso di fiducia rispetto alle proprie
capacità rispetto a quello che si aveva
che era il potere di fare e il pericolo
era quello proprio di superare i confini
della ragione e della modestia però
dobbiamo dirci una cosa dobbiamo essere
un po' sinceri con noi stessi ora quando
io vi parlo di temperanza e cioè della
giusta misura del Non esagerare della
moderazione rispetto alla yuris cos'è
che provate una noia tremenda Questo è
il problema perché se noi pensiamo agli
eroi tragici ma ci sembrano epici hanno
rischiato hanno fallito hanno vissuto
rovesci di fortuna hanno fatto delle
cose incredibili e sono rimasti nelle
nostre immaginario e chi li conosce
invece quelli che hanno esercitato La
Temperanza
immaginiamo e sono rimasti nelle loro
case con tanti libri da leggere le
piante odorose intorno della luce del
tramonto che li colpiva ma sempre
delicatamente e però Sì va bene il tempo
lento ma il tempo lento è molto poco
eccitante però non vi capita mai di
desiderarlo un po' quella noia nelle
vostre giornate più frenetiche perché è
vero che la iubris sembra più eccitante
Ma in fondo è del tutto insostenibile
eppure non riusciamo a considerare La
Temperanza come qualcosa di che non si è
noioso Ma lo sapete perché Perché è così
che veniamo educati la giusta misura non
ci sembra attraente viene spesso confusa
con la patia con non fare niente con non
provare emozioni Eppure l'equilibrio non
consiste nella rimozione delle emozioni
e non è dato una volta per tutte ma è
qualcosa che ogni volta si ridefinisce E
il frutto queste innumerevoli
ridefinizioni si può essere appassionati
entusiasti vivere una vita intensa ma
riuscendo a seguire la sua pressione La
Temperanza e non la ibris la tracotanza
e lo aveva già detto nel 1930 Bertrand
Russell grandissimo filosofo e
matematico quando scriveva che una
generazione che non sopporta la noia è
una generazione di persone piccole in
cui ogni impulso Vitale si spegne ed è
forse quello che si sta succedendo
perché essere tracotanti non fermarsi
mai competere continuamente anche solo
con se stessi non rende veramente più
felici è un'illusione e quindi dovremmo
mettere in discussione l'idea che una
vita serena sia una vita sprecata e
imparare a inserire dei momenti di
contemplazione di noia buona e di giusta
misura perché la giusta misura non è una
misura standard uguale per tutti non ha
a che fare la geometria o con l'algebra
Ma a che fare con la sensazione
in questo momento della tua vita senti
di aver trovato la giusta misura Forse
sì Io mi auguro che tanti di voi lo
sentano in questo momento però
sicuramente tra un po' di tempo sarà
necessario rimettersi ancora in
discussione e trovare una nuova giusta
misura Insomma l'avevo detto all'inizio
non ho un segreto da svelarvi questo non
renderà la vostra vita perfetta ma la
filosofia Antica Può ricordarvi che è
importante alternare Il ritmo non essere
tracotanti imparare a dosare il proprio
entusiasmo perché questo è essenziale
alla vita e perché la vita non è breve
ma è profonda e si può imparare ad avere
rispetto di sé e dei propri ritmi ad
avere una vita davvero sostenibile anche
a livello umano e questo si può fare
imparando l'arte della Temperanza O
almeno provandoci Grazie
[Musica]